RFK Jr in the race is a disaster for
Trump I don't want to say it seals it I
don't want to say that it makes it a
foregone conclusion he's going to lose
anything could happen in politics but it
puts him in an even deeper hole I mean a
really deep hole it just does
independent candidates always take more
from Republicans the Democrats but it's
an especially major problem for Trump uh
in this case for a number of reasons to
begin with RFK is uniquely able to
exploit the areas where Trump is weakest
if you vote for RFK Jr in the general
election you are ensuring that Biden
will be reelected you just are you're
putting Biden back in office